let's take some audience questions good
ones this week first is from Monique who
said hey when will you get an electric
car okay so there's a few different
aspects of this number one I'm hugely
supportive of getting off of fossil
fuels I've made it clear every time we
talk about Tesla I disclose that I have
been a shareholder of Tesla for a while
because I think that well if I believe
in the company why else would I have
bought shares of the company I have
driven hybrids before in the earlier
days of hybrids like I think it was nine
years ago so like three leases ago I had
a hybrid car in any case I don't know
when I'm going to have an electric car
my my current lease is up in like nine
months in Knight there's already
electric so many electric car options
now whether they're electric plug-in
vehicles versus hybrids or whatever I'm
going to assume that monique is talking
about a 100% electric car I don't know
if in nine months I would get an
electric car I guess I'd have to check
out what's available the cost how far
you can drive on one charge how
prevalent the charging stations are
although they're becoming more and more
prevalent and seeing them around in more
and more places but I don't know I mean
I think I would like to have an electric
car probably within the next five years
to the best of my knowledge most of
these cars that are entirely electric
can only go for maybe 40 miles at a time
is that right would hey I should get to
a point where I know you could go longer
distances you can go on road trips and
everything else and it's not an
inconvenience to have one I thought that
there were some that could go 200 miles
okay a charge although maybe that's just
what like the next generation Tesla will
be able to do which I don't see myself
getting any time soon yeah I mean maybe
technology is moving at a fast enough
rate where what I just said there was
old news at this point yeah but yeah I
would certainly consider getting a
hybrid certainly if all other factors
were the same if it was just about the
same when it comes to cost yeah the
thing about the hybrids is I don't know
if you've done some of the math on them
like I got this hybrid years ago because
I thought it was really cool but then
afterwards I found out that I probably
paid a something like $2,500 premium I
mean it was a lease but still there was
an extra twenty five hundred dollars of
cost figured into my lease payments
and that based on the number of miles
that I was limited to by the lease which
is like 12,000 that that $2,500 would
not have been made up for in fuel
savings so that financially I might have
made like a legitimately bad decision by
doing I didn't care enough to run the
numbers at the time it seems like people
are all about saving the world unless it
comes at a higher price and I'm guilty
of this too I think that's kind of human
nature yeah hopefully these will become
popular to a point where it's just as
affordable with the early hybrids though
there was an issue with the disposal of
the battery where not only were you
paying more and it was only a marginal
improvement in gas mileage that might
not even be made up at a certain point I
don't know if it was after if they had a
6 8 or 10 year life at the time the
hybrid batteries had to be disposed of
and those were quite corrosive not to
mention the fossil fuel cost to make the
battery in the first place so there was
actually a case made and again you read
all these different things and it is not
this is not such a central issue to my
life that I can speak completely
authoritative Leon it but I read some
articles that claimed that if you
consider the production of and disposal
of the battery your way outdoing the
benefit of an extra 15 or 20 percent gas
mileage or whatever it was what's really
unfortunate is that Trump is rolling
back some of the Obama era regulations
when it comes to fuel efficiency
standard that he had mapped out for the
next 10 20 years so if there's going to
be a trend towards more fuel-efficient
cars it's going to have to come entirely
from the consumers themselves and not
any government mandates yeah and that is
both sad and low-energy sadly so anyway
I think I don't know am I going to get
an electric car in 9 months for my next
car
probably not but I'm going to look into
it I'm definitely going to look into it
starting in about six months I will
start the research process and I will
absolutely keep you posted